Donnerstag Wien Wirtschaftsgipfel
business as usual so scheint es alles
wie immer und das in Wahrheit wenig wie
immer ist in dieser Nachwahl Woche
klingt schon am Montag an also erstmal
mir tut das Ergebnis wirklich leid ich
habe gestern die Daumen gedrückt und
hätte sehr gehofft dass die FDP
reinkommt Mitleid aus Sorge ums
gemeinsame Projekt denn nach der
Berlin-Wahl zeigt sich mehr denn je dass
von den drei Damen in ampelpartnern die
FDP den höchsten Preis zahlt einen am
Ende sehr hohen womöglich im schlimmsten
Falle Tod der Partei die Wiederholung
des Traumas von 2013 damals ist sie ja
nicht nur aus der Regierung
herausgefallen sondern sogar aus dem
Parlament obwohl sie mit der Union
regiert hatte also eigentlich mit dem
Wunschpartner das ist jetzt das
menetikel das über der Partei schwebt
längst zeigt sich eine Abwärtsspirale
seit der Bundestagswahl gab es in Folge
jeder verlorenen Landtagswahl auch
sinkende Zustimmungswerte im Bund auf
inzwischen fünf Prozent immer deutlicher
wird so das ganz prinzipielle Dilemma in
das sich die FDP hineingeampelt hat es
beginnt lange vorher mit der Absage an
Jamaika
wir werden unsere Wählerinnen und Wähler
nicht im Stich lassen indem wir eine
Politik mittragen von der wir im Kern
nicht überzeugt sind es ist besser nicht
zu regieren als falsch zu regieren damit
legte er die Latte hoch so hoch dass die
Ampel sie im Grunde nur reißen konnte
was man im Endorphin rauscht es sehr
viel Zeit offenbar über sah oder
ignorierte nun wird die lustlos
Situation immer deutlicher entweder man
regiert artig mit und vergrenzt so die
eigene kernwählerschaft oder man spielt
Opposition in der Regierung und wird
dafür von Wellen der Mitte abgestraft
Krawall oder kuscheln er war bislang
eher Team kuscheln und will es zum
Wochenanfang zumindest auch bleiben
wir folgen unserem Stil eins wird die
Partei der selbst Verantwortung
jedenfalls nicht machen mit dem Finger
auf andere zeigen nur Bill klingt das
doch führt das noble ins Nichts nicht
alle in der Partei mögen es so sanft die
Zeit des apisment sei vorbei heute etwas
Vize kubiki gebe es keinen Straßenbau
mehr gäbe es auch keine Stromleitung da
könne sich der Robert gehackt legen das
Team Krawalle könnte Zulauf bekommen in
der FDP nachdem der Robert ihren
Christian Mitte der Woche öffentlich
Angriff und zwar ziemlich frontal man
werde die haushaltseckwerte nicht
akzeptieren schrieb Habeck gleich im
Namen aller Grünen im Kabinett Lindner
antwortete überrascht und gereizt es
wäre für die Berechenbarkeit des Handels
der Bundesregierung insgesamt ratsam
wenn diese ihre eigenen Beschlüsse
achtet
also zunächst einmal sind das alles
Maßnahmen die gemeinsam auch beschlossen
wurden deswegen ist das befremdlich dass
ein solches Schreiben
stattgefunden hat dass ich
Koalitionspartner darüber austauschen
wie der Bundeshaushalt zu gestalten ist
und das natürlich zentrale Vorhaben des
Koalitionsvertrages umgesetzt werden
sollen das ist ja sozusagen was in einer
Koalition noch üblich ist und die
Kanzlerpartei hält sich weitgehend raus
sie ist selbst weit weg von den Werten
der Bundestagswahl und fordert von den
Liberalen nun Disziplin und Gehorsam
zu rudern und ständig nach profilprofil
zu rufen wird nicht helfen sondern es
geht vor allem um die
verantwortungsvolle Zusammenarbeit für
das Wohl des Landes was der SPD in
vergleichbarer Position als
Juniorpartner in groko Zeiten indes
selbst nicht ganz leicht viel ich bin da
festen Überzeugung dass wir genau diese
Problematik dass wir in Verhandlungen
mit der Union oft unsere Grundwerte
verlassen und dass die Menschen deswegen
am Ende nicht mehr wissen wofür steht
die SPD eigentlich die halte ich für
sehr problematisch und deswegen würde
ich empfehlen die Goku zu verlassen die
Koalition zu verlassen schließt die FDP
bislang aus es scheint aber immer
schwerer zu fallen dass trennende zu
kaschieren nun das sogar auf Briefpapier
steht schwarzer weiß und das zweieinhalb
Jahre vor der nächsten Bundestagswahl
sprich es ist noch sehr viel Ampel übrig
und zugeschaltet aus Bremen ist mir
jetzt Christian dürr der
FDP-Fraktionsvorsitzende im Bundestag
das ist genau in dem Ort Bremen wo die
nächste Landtagswahl auf sie zukommt
schönen guten Abend Herr guten Abend
Frau Bernd wir haben es gerade gesehen
die Lage für die FDP ist nicht einfach
sie haben fünf Wahlniederlagen
hintereinander kassiert wie wichtige
Wahl im Herbst in Bayern da sieht es
auch nicht besonders gut aus es gibt
eine aktuelle Forscher Umfrage gerade
mal zwei Tage alt da steht die FDP bei
drei Prozent trotzdem sagt ihr
Parteivorsitzender Christian Lindner er
möchte an seinem Kurs festhalten also in
dem Kurs mit dem sie reinweile rein
Weise Wahlen verlieren warum nee es geht
darum das Land zu wurde nie sehen da
geht's nicht zuerst um irgendwelche
Partei politischen Vorzüge weder bei SPD
grün noch bei uns sondern es geht darum
dass unser Land voranbringen und das
haben wir ja lange in Kauf entschuldigen
wir haben als Koalitionsregierung wir
haben letzten Jahr bewiesen dass wir es
können denken sie beispielsweise in
Niedersachsen an das LG Terminal oder
die umfangreichen Entlastungen Höhe von
über 50 Milliarden Euro für die hart
arbeitende Mitte jetzt ist einiges in
stockende geraten und das ist richtig
beispielsweise bei der
planungsbeschleunigung geht zum
Verkehrspolitik das haben wir klar im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart und Sie
haben ja einen Beitrag eben schon diesen
Brief zitiert wo teilweise die
Schuldenbremse in Frage gestellt wird
oder der Verzicht auf Steuererhöhung ich
finde wir sollten als Koalition zu dem
Zurückkehren was für vereinbart haben
mich das Land voranzubringen zu
modernisieren und dann sind wir auch
erfolgreich gemeinsam aber es geht
zuallererst um unser Land denn wir sind
eine modernisierungskoalition eine
fortschrittskoalition und da ist die FDP
der Motor wir sind manchmal das gebe ich
zu ungeduldiger als andere
Koalitionspartner aber gerade bei der
Frage der planungsbeschleunigung
Millionen von Pendler stehen jeden Tag
im Stau und sie erwarten von der neuen
Bundesregierung zu Recht Antworten
darauf dass der Grund warum wir ja auch
darauf bestehen das komplette Konzept
umzusetzen also auch Staus auf
Autobahnen in Zukunft zu vermeiden hilft
übrigens auch der Umwelt und hätte über
diese Antworten Streit wenn sie mit
ihren Koalitionspartnern zum Teil und
nicht alle sind in ihrer Partei sind der
Meinung dass man das nur harmonisch tun
sollte wir haben Herrn Kubicki gerade im
Zitat gehört der unter anderem sagt Herr
habe kann sich da gehackt legen das ist
ja ein neuer Tonfall den er damit
reinbringt ist das jetzt die Basis für
die Zusammenarbeit in den kommenden
Jahren in der Koalition es geht darum
gemeinsam das vereinbarte auch
umzusetzen und deswegen hat mich der
Brief von Robert habe schon sehr
gewundert denn da wird teilweise die
Schuldenbremse in Frage stellt es wird
über Steuererhöhung philosophiert alles
Dinge auf die wir uns ja geeinigt haben
dass das eine nicht kommt und dass wir
die Schuldenbremse einhalten was wir in
diesem Jahr übrigens tun auch die
Eckwerte des Bundeshaushalt sind ja vom
Kabinett beschlossen worden also alles
Dinge auf die wir uns bereits vereinbart
hatten wir sollten jetzt nicht langsamer
werden sondern wir sollten eher
schneller in der Modernisierung werden
denn die alte große Koalition das ist ja
auch im Einspieler deutlich geworden hat
ja vieles liegen gelassen und dafür sind
wir als FDP angetreten auch nach der
letzten Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
sind dann zum Glück Entscheidung die
wichtig waren für unser Land
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
getroffen deswegen hoffe ich jetzt dass
die Grünen wieder auf diesen
Modernisierungskurs zurückkommt das Land
gemeinsam voranzubringen das ist das
Ziel das ganze und da wird die FDP der
Motor sein wir werden auch diejenigen
sein die einem auf ein bisschen mehr
Geschwindigkeit drängen da sind wir
etwas ungeduldiger das gebe ich zu aber
nichtsdestotrotz es geht zuallererst
darum dass Deutschland erfolgreich ist
und wir sind bisher besser durch die
Krise gekommen als befürchtet das ist
auch hängt auch zusammen mit den
entlastungspaketen beispielsweise im
letzten Jahr oder unseren
energiepolitischen Entscheidung bevor
wir da den ganz großen Bogen schlagen
würde ich gerne noch mal bei der
Auseinandersetzung mit den Grünen
bleiben denn die sagen ja unter anderem
die FDP bemüht sich nicht genügend darum
ausreichend finanziellen Spielraum zu
schaffen für gemeinsame Projekte wenn
sie tatsächlich modernisieren wollen sie
beziehen sich da unter anderem auf das
Nein von Herr Lindner zu Einnahme
Verbesserungen warum hat die Ampel
darauf sich da nicht zu der verzagen die
FDP darauf sich da nicht zu bewegen ja
hinter dem Wort Einnahme Verbesserung
verwendet die da steht ja das Wort
Steuer in Wahrheit und das ist mit uns
nicht zu machen das wäre auch schlecht
für unser Land wir müssen ja die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit Deutschlands
erhöhen und gerade im letzten Jahr haben
wir die Steuern auf breiter Front
sozusagen für die hart arbeitende Mitte
deutlich reduziert über 50 Milliarden
ich sagte es vorhin für die
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland das fand wichtige Signale
auch Wachstumssignale damit unser Land
besser durch die Krise kommt als man
vielleicht zunächst annehmen konnte dazu
der Abbau von Subventionen
klimaschädlichen Subventionen die sind
auch im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
daran möchte sich die FDP nicht mehr
halten doch natürlich wir müssen ganz
konkret sprechen darüber um was es dann
dabei geht Frau energy also wenn es
beispielsweise darum geht beim Thema
Dienstwagen Steuern dann macht das wenig
Sinn es würde übrigens immense
Bürokratie nach sich ziehen wenn man von
der Pauschalbesteuerung wegkäme dazu
dass alle auf einmal wieder ein
Fahrtenbuch führen das wäre ja einfach
nur ein Aufbau von Bürokratie das kann
in Wahrheit keiner wollen das können
auch die Koalitionspartner das können
auch die Grünen in Wahrheit nicht wollen
wenn wir ein anderer Stelle über den von
Subventionen reden das ist mit uns immer
zu machen dem Bundeshaushalt zu
konsolidieren also unseren Kindern ein
gutes Staatsfinanzen zu hinterlassen das
ist unser gemeinsames Ziel da bin ich
sofort am Bord aber Steuererhöhung sind
wirklich das falsche Signal in einem
höchststeuer-land wie Deutschland weiter
gemeinsam auf Kurs bleiben das haben wir
verstanden soweit herzlichen Dank für
dieses Gespräch hätte ich danke Ihnen